let's chat with folks from the audience
we are going to take some calls at
davidpackman.com Discord that's how we
always take calls and I want to start
today with Jack from Atlanta Jack
welcome to the program
hey there David I appreciate you having
me on so I want to get straight to the
point please give me the gop's
disappointing uh performance across the
country in many areas well they still
did pretty good in Florida I'm going to
ask the one question on everyone's mind
will Ron DeSantis be the GOP 2024
nominee
I have no idea personally I I think you
know we'd we first don't even know
whether he's running but there is
definitely a shifting sense that
DeSantis is increasingly the leader of
the Republican party and there's sort of
two data points for that number one
Trump's picks the Contra you know the
contested ones it's easy to pick 50
incumbents and get almost all of them
right but Trump's controversial picks
the contested picks Oz lost mastriano
lost uh Herschel Walker was still
counting ballots almost certainly going
to a runoff Blake Masters losing Kerry
lay counting okay Etc
he doesn't make a big deal out of
endorsing DeSantis on the day before the
election goes yeah yeah re-elect
DeSantis and then it's DeSantis who over
performs by seven points and wins by 19.
so there is clearly a shifting wind
we're hearing from some Republican
insiders that they say this is the
opportunity to dump Trump and the
betting markets have now shifted such
that Ron DeSantis is favored in the
betting markets to be the Republican
nominee so without injecting my personal
opinion
just going into the facts it does seem
as though if both DeSantis and Trump run
it's not a given that this nomination
goes to Trump and this could make it a
very crazy two years
oh I agree it's gonna be uh one heck of
a ride so thank you very much David my
pleasure Jack from from Atlanta great to
hear from you